hi my name is Ed Boon I am the creative
director at NetherRealm Studios and
today we are doing Mortal Kombat 11
support OMG its maurice 1 says why does
sub-zero always get butchered in
promotional footage and trailers by
scorpion because scorpion is better
scorpion wins p ND ketchup the tactics
of MK 11 completely changed once you
enable crushing blow hole in the
controls being able to specifically
choose when you trigger those key moves
transforms the game for the better in
high level this option is mandatory
everybody's to start using it ASAP when
we originally decided to implement
crushing blows as we wanted to we did
want the dynamics of the fight to change
dramatically once you had a crushing
blow available that is by design and I
don't think we're gonna change that B
matter now ski guys I've been trying so
hard to get Scarlett's blood-trail
brutality and I can't get it I'm using
the amplify button and r2 at the same
time right I'm going at us sweet
distance can someone explain to me
please thanks in order to get that
brutality out you have to be further
than sweep distance you have to have
your blood mist move activated and you
have to do an amplified version of the
blood trail at 17 the Hitman says does
sweeping stop tech roll in this game I'm
not exactly sure what you're referring
to but when you tech roll I don't think
you are within sweep distance I would
say no at the game zombie says hey noob
D I made this just for you what do you
think I think you covered up the
dragon's face and you shouldn't do that
MK underscore forever King how do you
block counter-attack you know a
counter-attack is basically an attack
that happens while the other guy was
attacking so I'm not sure how you can
block it if you were in the middle of
attacking it's impossible to block the
counter-attack and if you meant
an attack that follows a perfect block
you cannot block it because that is the
advantage of getting a perfect block as
you get a free hit on the other guy so
hope that helps G marshmallow says what
could my mane be I like fast characters
I'd say scorpion or scarlet those are
fast characters unreal t think T V I and
K why do you make these flashes and it
shows a an image of somebody blocking
it's basically the little bang that
denotes that a an attack was blocked
that's just kind of the visual language
that we have in the game at Ashley Lynch
says how are the characters of mortal
combat not dead yet
I mean if it's up to MK 11 or whatever
now then how is it all of the original
characters except for one aren't dead
first of all it's a video game second of
all I don't think every character died
in mortal combat you have to look at the
story there's a lot of time messing that
we do with the story that explains
everything at mr. Meck stuff the more I
look at this image of noob saibot and
his shadow I feel more and more that a
shadow looks a lot like an enra revenant
smoke I know it sounds ridiculous but
maybe they merged together yeah let's go
with that at final round says can't we
all agree that Jackie's fatality is off
the wall pun intended
that's not funny
fly savage for how much skins do each
person get on Mortal Kombat 11 I will
try to translate that I'm gonna assume
you mean how many skins does each
fighter get I'm welcome at 11 it varies
some characters have more than others
more skins will be released throughout
the year expect to see a lot more
costumes than you see right now jaga
Jaguar what is the name of Kotal Kahn's
Jaguar he actually has two of them one
is named Maserati and one his name
Bentley a little fun fact for you I'll
pop his condom which sounds dirty but
I'm not gonna respond to that
are they going to top this this fatality
was iconic a classic a moment that's
Noob Saibot swear he tears his opponent
in half with the clone honestly I
thought maybe we crossed a line with
that one so I don't think we're gonna
top it at xox Raina says who was y'all
go to mortal combat fighter
mine was scorpion all day he was hella
bossy get over here
mine too and get over here to you too
at dr. wheat toast says you know it
would be cool for Mortal Kombat 11 bring
back the tag team just imagine the
potential we talked about it there is a
very cool kind of tag component in some
of the towers that I think you'll love
but as far as the main game we decided
not to do it when you see it in the
towers that much more special at Rose
dancer 5 says how long is MK 11 plan to
be supported as long as previous titles
are longer until next generation
consoles we're not going to support MK
11 that long we like to support our
games for as long as possible and for
Mortal Kombat 11 we are going to support
this game for the long foreseeable
future there's plenty of cool characters
and new game modes coming and you're
gonna love it and that's it thank you
for all of these great questions and I
hope you guys keep playing Mortal Kombat
11 and we'll keep looking for your
questions online get over here